in the latest edition of football
morning in america peter king breaks
down the antonio brown trading gets you
ready for free agency available now
at
profootballtalk.com okay uh chris i
think you've been hanging around me too
much buddy because i tend to be i tend
to be a little on the cynical side and i
don't know whether or not i always think
that there are conspiracy theories it's
kind of fun
because we know that there's always more
than meets the eye there's always
something going on behind the curtain
there's all you know very few things
happen accidentally or spontaneously in
the nfl everything is very planned out
so you suggested earlier and we didn't
really know exactly what we're going to
do in this segment there's so many
things to talk about the fruit is
falling out of the sky and landing in
our shoes right now seriously i want you
to lay out the theory that that you uh
you shared with me earlier and let's
just be clear before everybody blames
this on me this is chris sims theory not
mine although i may co-sign let's see
how he explains it go ahead well just a
theory i i really feel honored that
you're like you're setting the floor up
for me like this because this means it
must have made somewhat uh sense at
least to a degree
i'm saying you have to fail okay thank
you either way but i think to your point
yes very few things in the nfl are an
accident i mean we know there's a lot of
back channeling and conversations going
the nfl can talk about oh no talking or
tampering all you want but we know
tampering goes on i'm just throwing this
out there and i have no knowledge of
this but i just know a guy who's
followed football my whole life and
especially very closely here since my
career since i played and my career has
been over where i just looked at the
situation yesterday and said
what if
the oakland raiders and the antonio
brown camp drew rosenhaus the the agent
for antonio brown knew about the liking
of the oakland raiders for antonio brown
all along what if this was a master plo
employee all along antonio brown hey
we're the oakland raiders we really want
you we need you we need a broad receiver
we got a young quarterback he's really
good i'm john gruden i am amazing at
drawing players for wide receivers and
oh you want money you want more
guaranteed money mr big chest no problem
we got it but the one thing i'm not
liking about this is i don't want to
trade away my first round picks i have a
lot of holes in my team i have a lot of
holes i have to fill in i really don't
want to give away those how can we maybe
get you i'll pay you your money and we
don't have to give away some of my
high-end picks you know what antonio how
about you go on social media and just
act a fool and just start dictating
things and making videos and go on the
shop with lebron james and lower your
trade value so now where we don't have
to trade away one of our first round
picks and we can get you for a third and
five and we'll get you here you get you
out of pittsburgh and we'll get you that
money you want i'm just saying those are
things that i've i've heard happen
before and i don't know if this happened
now but i wouldn't shock me if this
became true somewhere down the road
and think about football everything
about it is strategic it's detailed it's
all planned out and it doesn't end when
the season ends especially when you have
a very creative and fertile mind like
the one that belongs to john gruden i
mean that guy's getting up at 3am not to
go sit in his office and and watch
reruns of seinfeld and they're working
right and and when you can't work with
your players when you can't really do
the kind of thing that coaches do then
you can you can spend that time doing
other things like coming up with ways to
make your team better and thinking
outside the box and
what a shock that a team may may
fracture a ruler to in the process it's
the ultimate machiavellian enterprise
here where all's fair in love and war
and football and of all teams to have
this happen al davis wouldn't al davis
would have done it
he was still around right now he's
smiling right now he loves that they got
this done and got antonio brown he's a
perfect stealer it just makes but but so
wait so you kind of like like my theory
a little bit you're not shocked by it
either is what you're telling me though
no no i i kind of like it i mean it's
the same
it's not the same it's kind of like the
the flip side of my idea that the
steelers were bound and determined to
get rid of him because at some point ben
rothersburg went to the steelers and
said it's him or it's me which wouldn't
shock me we know things like that have
happened and we know how ben
roethlisberger is and you look at how
much antonio brown has agitated ben
roethlisberger as part of this right
it's been
brown sang and doing things to get out
of pittsburgh but he keeps poking and
poking at ben roethlisberger at one
point brown weaponized twitter against
roethlisberger he found a couple of
tweets mentioning roethlisberger's
sexual assault cases from 10 years ago
and he pressed that little like button
so you go to antonio brown's list of all
the tweets he's liked and the top two
were about roethlisberger and his past
accusations of sexual assault if if the
line hadn't been crossed before then it
sure as hell was crossed with that move
and i think that that between maybe the
raiders trying to set this up right and
roethlisberger wanting this guy out even
though he's still one of the best
receivers in the nfl i i think that it
all makes sense this isn't something
that just happened out of the blue and
this isn't simply antonio brown wanting
out there's a lot of layers to this that
we may never know the full extent of but
but it could be the only way to
logically explain whatever it is that
that has happened that such a great
player ends up being given away for a
three and a five well i and i remember
you know i don't know if it was last
week or the week we're at the combine
where you said a comment like maybe
antonio brown's either lost his mind
he's going crazy or he's really smart
and knows something we don't and he's
planning something and i don't know when
i see you know one of the best receivers
at the over the age of 30 i understand
that lowers his trade value and all of
that but when i see a guy act the way he
did
and get traded only for a third and a
fifth and also get what he wanted on the
back end there sometimes they just go oh
the setup was in maybe uh you know like
i said to start the the seven o'clock
hour too i was i was told by many people
there was no market for antonio brown i
mean most teams got no further than just
really a call let me just see what
they're asking for and that was it most
teams deemed him as we don't want him on
our team
radioactive was one of the phrases i was
told by uh somebody that who had
knowledge of the the the situation in
general so i think that shows you too i
just wonder if they were smart enough
drew rosen asks antonio brown to set it
up this way to get it done just throwing
it out there conspiracy theory do you
believe there was a second man on the
grassy knoll or do you think oswald was
the lone gunman
are we really going there i want to know
i just wanted to know your thought on
that real quick i i i think it's a
mystery of which we'll never know the
answer but it sure
that was one magic loogie as jerry
seinfeld once said um so uh uh anyway
back you really threw me with that i
know you did i really do wonder though
if this happened if this happened right
because we're gonna have players who are
inspired and emboldened by what antonio
brown did and this is the ultimate way
to turn the tables chris another point
you made during the break and it's very
appropriate here we have seen for years
as the start of the league year
approaches what happens teams rip up
contracts one after the other they
exercise their rights under those deals
to tell guys see you later right and
guys have not had the equal opportunity
to say i want out it's always been a
one-way situation where the team either
honors the contract or doesn't but the
player is expected to always honor the
contract this gives an opening and the
question becomes how many other players
will try to do the same thing and chris
if you've got stuff going on behind the
scenes like now i'm sitting here
thinking who is odell beckham jr going
to work with to try to get out of new
york and is it going to happen now does
it happen next year what do you do if
you're odell beckham to follow what
antonio brown did and also supersede it
because what's going to happen for
beckham he's going to have brown now
making more money than him and tyree
kill is going to make more money than
beckham and julio jones is going to make
more money than beckham and michael
thomas is going to make more than
beckham at what point does beckham snap
and say
i uh sorry i know i signed this deal
that covers six seasons but there's no
way the team's going to honor it so i
don't want to honor it either i want a
new contract yeah i i mean
i'd be lying if i didn't think about
odell beckham jr yesterday and just
sitting there watching as this all
unfolded and hearing all the stories
going man i wonder what odell's thinking
about this i wonder if odell is really
happy in new york all of those things uh
go through my brain i think the big
thing is that antonio brown did and what
he showed and what i don't know if other
players are always going to have the
guts to see it through because hey
players for the most part they want to
be liked i mean they're human beings and
they're used to people liking them
antonio brown showed that he didn't give
a damn whether people liked him and
that's the presidency set too so yeah he
got what he wanted but he also was
willing to stand in there in the fire
for the last few weeks and we all called
him a renegade and what's he doing this
is a horrible approach i mean we talked
about him we said a lot of unflattering
things about his approach but he was
willing to do that to get what he wanted
and that's where i think star players
will really have to figure out are they
willing to go down that that you know
lane to go okay i'm gonna become enemy x
in my home territory and a lot of other
cities other than the team i just end up
playing for when all said and done if
players can swallow that this is their
play going forward to where yeah they
can gain a little leverage against the
owners and and the way the current cba
is set up
and the way that that the fans have
reacted over the years to that that
disconnect between owners and players
when the owners make shrewd business
decisions they get applauded when the
players try to do it they get vilified
you know what let's let's let's play
let's play this out yeah all right let's
move it a few steps forward now that
brown has taken a stand and he's won and
he's flexed his muscles and he's emerged
with more power
at some point a team is going to feel
compelled and maybe it will be john mara
to odell beckham jr if beckham tries to
make a power play maybe a team is going
to try to play hardball with a player
and when that happens
how will we react
as media and fans when a team says you
have signed a contract and you are
obligated and we will seek the repayment
of bonus money and we will suspend you
for conduct detrimental to the team and
you know it takes us back to 2005 and
i've always said terrell owens was ahead
of his time right in trying to get more
for what he was giving to the team and
he got he got ripped mercilessly for
that the next time there's a showdown
like that the steelers chose not to
engage in it but the next time there's a
showdown like that chris will we align
with the player or will we align with
the team and i think more people will
now be inclined to align with the player
after what antonio brown pulled off i
think so i hope so i mean hey the
billionaire owners they got a billion
dollars as is and yes you know to your
point it always drives me crazy i mean
yeah antonio brown he's not you know you
look at the comments under some of the
articles you wrote under pro football
talk anything like that it's all
negative other than raiders fans raiders
fans are the only people that like
antonio brown in the country now
everybody else hates him and thinks he's
a jerk which you know i understand he's
not perfect for everybody but again this
was a business decision that he made and
it might not be perfect but he got what
he wanted in the end of the day and i
just hope people can appreciate the
lack of different ways players can play
business with the way the cba is set up
again i want to sit here and go you know
we always hear about all these players
sign contracts and you know they got to
honor the the players that honor the
contract well hey the jacksonville
jaguars let go malik jackson and
shashawn gibson the cowboys asked sean
lee to restructure his contract this
year i can go on and on with players and
there's never those comments underneath
those articles going the team signed a
contract they need to honor that drives
me freaking crazy the hypocrisy in that
and why people would side with the
billion dollar owner who they have
nothing in common with over the player
who works hard and they have a lot more
in common with than they realize
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports